dominada por mujeres así estuvo la
premiación del festival de venecia
florida en brasilia nos enamoramos de
esa película fue una decisión unánime
calderón ryan el león de oro para la
mejor película es leve en el
acontecimiento por objetivo
la francesa otro tibán se convirtió en
la sexta mujer en ganar el prestigioso
león de oro por la película le vemos la
cinta es la adaptación de una novela
homónima que relata la dura experiencia
de una joven en el proceso de un aborto
clandestino
por su parte la española penélope cruz
se alzó con el premio de la mejor actriz
el reconocimiento bueno por la película
dirigida por su coterráneo pedro
almodóvar madres paralelas que entre las
al tema de la maternidad con la memoria
histórica española en el cierre del
festival cruz narró su experiencia
encarnando el papel de una de las madres
el personaje fue hermosamente escrito
fue muy difícil muy desafiante alegre el
festival más antiguo del planeta mostró
que cada vez más las mujeres abren un
camino en el mundo del cine
internacional
[Aplausos]